[Musique]
les porteurs de projets peuvent donc
nous présenter toute action en lien donc
avec la transformation alimentaire en
lien avec le développement qui lire
local de vente directe d'amélioration de
la qualité en rive environnementale
d'action en faveur de la biodiversité ou
encore de développement en termes
d'agriculture biologique et d'innovation
donc c'est très vaste dans le champ de
du développement de l'agriculture
ils peuvent avoir donc des subventions
aux niveaux au niveau de la région par
exemple au niveau du programme leader
européen ils peuvent avoir des des prêts
au niveau de leur banque mais parfois ça
ne suffit pas pour pouvoir enclencher le
projet est donc c'est un petit plus qui
est apportée par l'agglomération
ça a été mis en place toute fin 2019
l'année 2009 a été on va dire un peu
particulière tout le monde le sait on a
quatre porteurs de projets qui sont déjà
manifestés là pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
les accompagner donc les projets sont
maintenant en étude